boy scouts reach 850 million dollar
settlement with tens of thousands of
sexual abuse victims this is an nbc news
story
tens of thousands of people who say they
were sexually abused while scouts
and filed suits against the boy scouts
of america have reached an 850 million
settlement the largest in a child sexual
abuse case in united states history more
than 84 000 people were
part of a lawsuit against a 110 year old
organization which has been plagued with
claims
of abuse from volunteers and leaders
since the 1960 the boy scouts of america
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy last
year and it's faces mounting legal costs
for defendants
self against claims of sexual abuse
against boys boy scouts leadership has
insisted that scouting
is safer now than ever before 90 percent
of claims against the organization
occurred more than 30 years ago okay
thoughts since you were part of it what
do you have to say about you know man
it's a shame dude it's such a shame
because
the the boy scouts was a lot of fun and
it's something that you know we should
all be learning we should be learning
these survival skills we should be
learning camping we should be learning
this stuff
and community is so important man and i
feel similar to the catholic church i
grew up catholic
and my whole family's still catholic and
i i just it was
look man it was an unforgivable it was
an unforgivable thing for me what
happened with the catholic church it was
unforgivable
their response to it and now it's coming
out with
it's very obvious that this has been a
problem for decades decades that they've
been trying to hide
and it it's the cover-up is worse than
the crime man like
you know the the if there's a pedo if
there's pedophiles in your ranks
root them out and be obvious about and
say we found this we apologize my god
it can't get worse than this and we're
gonna do everything we possibly can do
to make sure that we're not fostering an
environment for these people in the
future
but instead like paying people to go
away and spending 30 years trying to
cover this stuff up and like
who's going to jail dude who's going to
freaking jail
not one freaking face i go online i look
this up
not one effing guy and
go online look this up people
they're putting like a cap on when you
can come out with your story as well
so like if you meet don't hit that
deadline
limitations right and then my question
you had like you run
people dude you know with the insurance
how are they going to survive with the
liability insurance moving forward
because i would assume that like that
money is
uh not coming yeah you know to these
people i mean i would be very surprised
but
i mean anyone that has been abused i
mean yeah money
i guess that'll help but not really oh
yeah you need convictions man like we
need to see
like mother efforts going to jail dude
like
not one person that i read about is like
oh yeah this person is
held accountable i think we need
accountability in this world
that that's a good point but here's what
i will say do you have any comments on
this or no i mean i got a lot of
comments on this because
go forward look i i was never part of
the boy scouts
uh i remember it's it's ironic here that
says the this occurred more than 30
years ago
i remember being 10 years old i'm 40 and
10 years ago i get
brought out in the middle of summer uh
summer camp boy scout camp
one day my buddy one of my best friends
is like oh we're gonna be a boy scouts
i got out there and you know just when
something you know it just doesn't feel
right
i'm out there it's sweaty as hell people
are talking about sleeping in tents
i'm good i'm out yeah some weird [ __ ]
was happening i just felt it i
i just i said you know what i'm gonna go
play some ball play some football
basketball
the boy scouts always felt weird to me i
don't know i i don't know how you made
it out alive between being boy scouts in
the catholic church
thank god that you're not i was a i was
a chubby kid i wasn't very popular
you weren't a hot kid bro you always
wondered why not me
yeah why not me but you know short clip
short clip you didn't have what it took
when you were 10 years old
it's been nice being on this podcast
sorry bro i just the boy scouts to me
always felt
creepy and weird and sleepovers and it
just validates like the weirdness that
was going on
tens of thousands of kids were molested
this is like a worse cover from the it
was
it was the worst america where's kept
saying it's ridiculous he used to make
fun of this on family guys
on family movers intense and this is
acceptable yeah dude
this is so beyond the road and i get
that there's good parts of it you know
you
learn no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no dude
look out i'm disappointed i'm
disappointed but i am in no
way defending them and this is my own
family my own family
i've we we've just had you can't talk
about it anymore i was raised very
strict irish catholic
and it's like that's their immediate
go-to well the good out way is the bad
the
catholic church does more good i'm like
no absolutely not that's not what we're
doing here
we're not justifying we're not
equivocating no no this is bad
and there's there's no answer for the
bad yeah except to get rid of
me let me ask you a question let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
memberships have declined 61 since 2019.
yeah let me say that one more time
61 they tried to open it up to girls
that was their response like
five didn't three years ago they tried
to open it up to women here's the
question for you here's the question for
you
so so take so at this point are these
guys going to make it or no
no okay so let's just say boy scouts
goes what happens with the girl scouts i
want to know
anyway hear me by the girl scout that's
a whole different business model that
we'll talk
about here but say they go out of
business they're done okay
what do you send your boys to to go
learn how to you know learn the
principles of what it is to
there's a lot of our kids i went to boy
scouts uh what do you call it uh
uh with tikkun dylan when they said oh
you you need if they sleep over for this
many nights they get a badge i said i
really don't give a [ __ ] about the badge
yeah
i'm not doing no sleepover with this
they're going to be sleeping over on my
house
michael jackson but we went and we shot
they shot right
they shot rifles they shot a few
different things it was like slingshots
it was actually a good experience
i enjoyed it for the day that i was with
them so accountability is on a few
different things
there's a level of accountability on the
people that took advantage there's a
level of accountability on the parents
that we're not watching and saying hey
just go out there and like the kid the
guy that was giving you his son for
three hours a day
and you're teaching them how to hit the
baseball yeah i'm just pretty pretty
much a glorified expensive babysitter is
what you were right
so the parents are like ah you know
whatever go do whatever you wanna do my
kids
there's a level of accountability on the
parents right there so organization
leadership at the top is where it goes
because you look if it's eighty four
thousand it's not like it's
22 yeah yeah it's 88 it's 84 000 cases
we're talking about now here's the other
part check this out
members of the boy scouts over the year
buzz aldrin
neil armstrong neil armstrong
bill gates hank aaron willie banks
josh hart michael jordan d michael
jordan tommy lasorda
uh uh nolan ryan mark spitz steve young
uh uh the list goes on by martin luther
king
jr d mlk jon bon jovi jimmy buffett
harrison ford zach galifianakis that's
where they screwed up
andy griffith okay jay leno okay this
thing i can go on but chris pratt and
mike rowe steven spielberg jimmy
stewart john wayne michael bloomberg
okay george w bush clinton
gerard ford john f kennedy ross perot
jeff sessions i can go on and on
and on and on communities so
in self-preservation good
i had a guy that i work in the insurance
industry was an eagle scouts he tells me
go go meet an eagle scouts
hire them free cops higher eagle scouts
if you can find them
the problem with this is this is such
terrible 61 since 2019 yeah
to do that that is not good i have an
easy solution
no sleepovers do your stuff during the
day
do your your shooting what do you do you
know help help old lady crossing
i don't know who it was but they said
the freaks come out at night first of
all i think that was who the sergeant in
the army once told me
hey rule of thumb never have a girl in
your barracks
from the army without another person
watching where it's just like
the door's always got to be open just
don't do it
because one of our guys came out and
this girl came out he didn't want to be
with her he just
she came out and she said you know he
took advantage of me
he's like dude i promise you i was just
sitting there with him because he had no
interest in her
she later on says nothing ever happened
i just he lost rank
yeah nothing ever happened so i think
there's a part of it where
the only way they can do sleepover is if
a parent accompanies them if not we're
not doing it there's certain systems you
can do
all i'm saying is there's still you got
to still have
like this whole thing with lawsuits
where kids were falling off of a at
parks and breaking bones until
lawyers were suing them and then cities
started getting rid of their parks and
they got kids that can't not play
there is negative ramifications to this
as well you definitely got to fire the
entire leadership team if you're going
to recreate you're huge on
on predictive analytics right like at
some point we have to start looking at
these things
we have to start looking at these things
and say okay catholic church
boy scouts okay what what did they have
in common and what are we not
investigating right now do they need a
spokesperson pat
oh this listen you got to bring somebody
oh yeah like an athlete like someone
look at what they do look at what the
houston asteroids
who did houston astros bring houston
astros brought who they're so canceled
they brought they brought bobby bonds he
used to astros who did they bring to
help them out with their uh
uh uh bestie baker not bobby bunny they
brought dusty pig
dusty baker came in like look i
understand what happened we got to clean
everybody likes dusty yeah so
you need a leader that comes in that
america
trust that america says okay let's see
what this person close it down rebrand
start over you kind of do need to do
that close it down
there's a lot of problems so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you